and joining us now secretary of the
treasury steven
mnuchin mr secretary welcome back to fox
news sunday
thank you it's good to be with you house
democrats passed their relief bill back
in may
fully two months ago but here we are the
last week
in july and the white house and senate
republicans still can't agree on just a
gop
package meanwhile a federal ban on
evictions ran out yesterday
federal unemployment benefits run out on
friday and the first
the last checks have already gone out
and the payroll protection program for
businesses is running out early next
month
here's senate democratic leader chuck
schumer
they have been so divided so
disorganized so
unprepared that they have struggled to
even draft a partisan proposal within
their own conference
they can't come together
won't millions of americans and millions
of businesses pay the price because the
white house
and senate republicans can't get your
act together
well chris first let me say i think
that's an unfair characterization
the administration and the senate
republicans are completely on the same
page
mark meadows and i were up yesterday
just working on technical issues
in the drafts we had previously agreed
on all these issues earlier in the week
we want to move forward quickly the bill
will be introduced
monday and we're prepared to act quickly
this is all about kids and jobs this is
our focus
and we want to make sure something gets
passed quickly so that we deal with the
unemployment
and all the other issues paycheck
protection plan
tax credits to rehire people and money
for schools
but but mr secretary the plan was
supposed to be announced uh on wednesday
then thursday now it's next week and
it's two months after the democrats came
up with their plan and now you're going
to have to start
negotiating with democrats now that you
have
a republican plan senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell said friday
hopefully we can come together behind
some package we can agree on
in the next few weeks and here's white
house chief of staff mark meadows
we're trying to make sure that we hit
the immediate needs first
and then continue to negotiate perhaps
throughout most of
august until we get something finished
so do you have a gop plan that will be
announced tomorrow
and and then what are
laid off workers and what are struggling
businesses supposed to do
while you spend as the white house chief
of staff just said
until sometime in august negotiating
with democrats
well let me first say we do have an
entire plan
it's a trillion dollars and let me just
remind everybody
that of the three trillion dollars we've
already passed we have about a trillion
to a trillion and a half still left to
put into the economy
so these are very very large amounts of
money working with congress to support
this
and what mark meadows was saying is that
within the trillion dollar package there
are certain things
that have time frames that are a bigger
priority
so we could look at doing an entire deal
we could also look at doing parts so
obviously the most pressing
issues are the fact that we have
unemployment insurance running out
we need to make sure that we don't have
frivolous lawsuits for schools and
universities
we want to make sure with the expiring
unemployment insurance we have the
technical fix so people don't get paid
more
to stay home than they do to work and
we can move very quickly with the
democrats on these issues we've moved
quickly before
and i see no reason why we can't move
quickly again
and if there are issues that take longer
uh we'll we'll deal with those as well
but but mr secretary you know because
nancy pelosi has made it very clear
she's not going to agree to a piecemeal
plan because the things that you want
immediately
are the things that you want and there
are things they want and they're not
going to
agree to to some things until everything
is agreed to
let's focus if we can specifically on
on the unemployment benefits because
that
seems to be the big hold up certainly
among republicans
the the plan that is just running out
now provided a federal
unemployment benefit on top of state
unemployment benefits
a federal benefit of 600
a week you're saying that's too much how
much do you plan
to reduce it and why well chris
just remember when we did the last plan
and let me say you know when you talk
about piecemeal this will be the fifth
set of legislation so there's no reason
why we can't have number five
six and seven as we need to deal with
issues and obviously anything we knew
we do we need bipartisan support but as
it relates to unemployment insurance
we we knew there was going to be large
unemployment we had a technical issue
with the states and how they were going
to be able to do this
so we picked a number that on the
average
looked okay but what we've seen is now
that we want to have the technical
correction
and we want to have something which pays
people about 70 percent wage replacement
which i think
is a very fair level so it's not a fixed
number
it's something that pays you a
percentage of your wages that are lost
and let me just say
last time people thought we'd have 40 or
50 million people
unemployed the good news is we never got
anything like that and matter of fact
we've created and brought back an
enormous number of jobs
so all these different pieces have to
work together where it's the paycheck
protection program
or whether it's the direct payments we
send or whether it's the money to
schools
all this works together so ui is just a
component of the overall
economic package which everybody wants
the same thing
which is let's get kids back to school
where it's safe and let's get workers
back to their jobs
when i did my interview with president
trump last week he said that he might
veto a bill that did not include
a payroll tax cut that now is gone from
all the discussions
why did the administration cave on that
so quickly
well in our conversations with pelosi
and schumer it was very clear
that the democrats were not going to
give us a payroll tax cut
so that's something the president will
come back and look at later in the year
but the money goes through if if if i
may if i may just briefly
it wasn't just democrats there were a
number of republicans who rejected this
uh i'm going to put them up on the
screen some of the top republican
leaders in the senate john
thune john cornyn chuck grassley the
head of sonnet finance they all said
they had no interest in that and well so
you got you got blow back not just from
democrats but from some top republicans
as well
there were other republicans that
supported it and and let me just say
again we know we need bipartisan support
we have tax credits that we've put in
here to incentivize people
to get back to work and in small
businesses to hire people
we have the direct payments and as you
know the direct payments are a much
quicker way
of effectively giving everybody a tax
cut and it's much quicker than the
payroll tax cut
meanwhile 32 you say we don't have 40
million unemployed we do have 32 million
people
unemployed and more people applied for
jobless benefits last week
uh 1.4 million than it applied the week
before
so new unemployment was is going up not
not down meanwhile we're seeing this
surge
uh in the virus and more and more states
are either delaying
or actually rolling back uh some of
their reopenings
isn't this going to have a an effect on
the recovery
and is there a possibility of a double
dip recession
well chris let me just point out as you
said you know we got to 30 we never got
to 40 or 50. that's a huge difference
and we created almost 10 million jobs
since then
so we are in a very different situation
there are parts of the economy
that are doing very well uh there are
parts of the economy that aren't and
there are places like new york and new
jersey which were
very big problems at the time have
recovered significantly
and there's other areas where there's an
issue so yes we are going to put more
money in the economy we want to support
workers small business kids going back
to school
and and those are our priorities
gdp numbers will be released for the
second quarter
on thursday and the atlanta fed is
projecting
that the gdp number for the second
quarter nationally will not be the the
plus one or two or three percent that we
normally see
but instead for the second quarter will
be something like minus
33 percent one is that
what we should expect to see a
contraction of the economy by
a third in the second quarter and
secondly if it's anything like that
why would you want to cut back on the
600
stimulus payments the unemployment
benefits because
there are projections that even if you
cut it to around 200
which is basically what i think you're
talking about with a 70-75 percent
of wages there are estimates that that's
going to cost
millions of jobs well chris we always
said
the the second quarter was going to be a
very bad quarter again that's not for
economic reasons that's for health
reasons
we literally shut down the entire
economy
and i think as we've said we expect the
third quarter
uh the consensus is 17 gdp
so we do think you're going to see a
very big rebound i might just also
comment on june retail sales were one
percent higher
than june of last year so all that money
we pumped into the economy
it worked people went out and spent and
on the you know as it relates to the
unemployment insurance again
i think workers and americans understand
the concept
that you shouldn't be paid more to stay
home than to work that the fair
thing is to replace wages and it just
wouldn't be fair to use taxpayer dollars
to pay more people to sit home than they
would get working and get a job
secretary mnuchin thank you thanks for
your time always good to talk with you
sir
thank you chris